Zero: Hello, little Human.
I am Zealously Empathetic
Robotic Organism.
You may call me ZERO.
Zero: I will help you humans.
I read in my guide to
Earth that humans like ozone.
Ozone will protect you
from harmful UV rays.
But I need to get
my tank of ozone.
[Zap]
Zero: Okay, now I am ready. [Pleasant music]
Get ready for my
protection, humans.
Protect!
Marathon dude: [coughs]
Zero: Protect!!
Lady: [Coughs violently]
Zero: Feel the warmth of
my protection, humans.
Protecting...
Little Boy: [crying]
Zero: Feel the warmth
of my protection!
Zero: PROTECT!
Scientist: [coughs]
Scientist: Aah!
Why did you just do that?
What did you just
spray me with?
Zero: It says in my guidebook
that the ozone layer protects
humans from UV rays.
I have sprayed
you with ozone.
You are now protected, Human.
You are welcome.
Scientist: No,
man, you're wrong.
Well, sort of...
I'm a research scientist,
I know this stuff.
Here, come with me.
Scientist: I think you're
a little bit confused about
ozone, so I'm going
to explain it to you.
First, it's important
to know that ozone is a
chemical-specifically a gas-with a chemical structure of (O3).
Here, we're almost at my lab.
Scientist: Come with me,
there's a special room
in the back that I
would like to show you.
Scientist: We call this
our periodic table room;
here, have a look.
Zero: Oh, look!
There is iridium; that
is what the currency
on my planet is made of.
Your money is
worthless, Human.
Scientist: So, as I was
saying, ozone is (O3),
meaning it's composed
of 3 oxygen atoms.
Zero: Contradiction, Human!
I thought oxygen atoms are
what you humans breathe.
Scientist: You're right,
but the difference between
the oxygen we breathe and
ozone is that oxygen gas is
the molecule (O2),
and ozone is (O3).
Because of this
difference, they each have
different properties.
Zero: Query, what are
the properties of ozone?
Scientist: Well first, you
need to know that there are
two different
types of ozone.
Let's go outside
and I can show you.
Scientist: The first
kind of ozone is called
stratospheric ozone.
It exists in what is
called the ozone layer,
which is about 6 to 30 miles
above the surface of the earth.
The other kind of ozone is
called tropospheric ozone.
It is located at the
earth's surface.
Zero: Query, what else
makes stratospheric and
tropospheric
ozone different?
Scientist: Well for one,
how they are formed.
I think we're going to need
a different perspective.
Hmm...
Zero: I have a hypothesis.
I am equipped with a solution!
Hang on tightly.
Scientist: [with outrage] Hey!
Couldn't you have
given me a heads up?
Zero: Oopsies.
Scientist: Fine!
Where was I?
Zero: You were describing how
stratospheric ozone is formed.
Scientist: Oh
yes, that's right.
First of all, here's
the stratosphere.
So stratospheric ozone
is naturally formed when
ultraviolet rays interact
with oxygen gas, (O2),
in the stratosphere.
The photons from the UV
rays break the (O2) apart into
two separate
single oxygen atoms.
Then an individual oxygen
atom bonds with an (O2),
to make (O3), or ozone.
Scientist: Now will you
please take me back to earth?
Zero: Information
input computes.
Query, why does
stratospheric ozone
only form in the stratosphere?
Scientist: Good question.
You asked me earlier what
the properties of ozone are.
One property is that it
is unstable, much more so
than oxygen gas, or (O2).
Scientist: Because of
this, stratospheric ozone
cannot exist on the
earth's surface, where
atmospheric pressure and
temperature are so high.
Scientist: These conditions
would cause the unstable
ozone to decay and revert
into oxygen gas, or (O2).
Scientist: But, higher
up in the atmosphere,
pressure and temperature
are much lower, making it
a better place for
stratospheric ozone.
Zero: Query-so what about
tropospheric ozone?
How does that form?
Scientist: So tropospheric
ozone is unlike stratospheric
ozone because it is not natural.
It is formed by
photochemical reactions
between air pollutants,
mainly VOC and NOx.
Zero: Query!
What's all that
stuff about?
Scientist: Well, a photochemical
reaction is a reaction that
requires the absorption
of light energy to occur.
Scientist: VOC stands for
Volatile Organic Compounds.
These are usually in
the form of gases.
Scientist: NOx stands for
Nitrogen Oxides, such as
(NO), nitrogen oxide, and
(NO2), nitrogen dioxide.
Both VOC and NOx are
types of air pollutants.
Zero: Pollutant does
not sound very good.
Query, where do these
pollutants come from?
Scientist: You're
right, it isn't good.
Here, follow me.
Scientist: The simple
answer is that these
pollutants come from humans.
Specifically, cars,
factories, and more
release VOCs and
NOx into the air.
Scientist: Then these
pollutants react to
form tropospheric ozone.
Zero: Query, why doesn't
tropospheric ozone revert to
oxygen gas, just like
stratospheric ozone would if
it were in the troposphere?
Scientist: Well, it does.
The thing is that humans
produce so many pollutants, that
they are constantly refilling
the troposphere with ozone.
Scientist: [Coughs] But
let's get out of here;
this place isn't
good for my health.
Zero: Query, what do you mean
"isn't good for
your health," Human?
Scientist: Well, because the
tropospheric ozone is made from
pollutants, it is
a pollutant itself,
which makes it
harmful to humans.
Scientist: It's also
a greenhouse gas that
contributes to
global warming.
Zero: This is much
information to compute.
Let me check if I
am understanding.
Scientist: Go ahead.
Zero: Stratospheric ozone forms naturally in the ozone layer
up in the stratosphere.
Scientist: Yes, 6 to 30
miles above the earth.
Zero: And tropospheric
ozone forms on earth's
surface from the reaction
of air pollutants.
In addition, tropospheric
ozone is harmful to human
health and is a
greenhouse gas.
Scientist: Yup,
that's correct.
Zero: Query, if
tropospheric ozone is bad,
is stratospheric
ozone also bad?
Scientist: Actually no.
This goes back to
when you were first
spraying people with ozone.
You were half right when
you said that ozone protects
people from UV rays.
Zero: Hypothesis validated!
I am helpful!
Zealous Empathy wins again.
Scientist: Only
stratospheric ozone
protects people from UV rays.
Would you mind taking
us back to space?
Scientist: Thanks.
Scientist: So as I was saying,
ozone becomes a sort of
natural shield that absorbs 93
to 99% of all harmful UV rays,
which can cause skin cancer
and cataracts in people.
Scientist: But this only
happens in the stratosphere.
You, on the other hand,
were spraying people with
tropospheric ozone because
you were on the earth's surface.
Zero: Conundrum, isn't
tropospheric ozone
bad for human health?
[Gasp] Did I hurt
those humans?
Scientist: Well, it
definitely wasn't good for them.
However, I don't think you
sprayed them with enough
ozone to cause
any real problems.
Zero: If I felt
emotions-it would be relief.
Query, if I had sprayed
them with more ozone, then
what would have been
the negative effects?
Scientist: Well, there
are actually a lot.
Let's get back to
the earth so that
I can show you some examples.
Scientist: Thanks.
So when a human breathes
in tropospheric ozone,
the ozone damages the
respiratory tract, leading to
respiratory symptoms,
reduced lung function, and
airway inflammation.
Scientist: In severe cases,
ozone can even cause death.
Zero: Such a sad
tragedy for inferior
carbon-based life forms.
Zero: Human, list the
respiratory symptoms!
Scientist: The main respiratory
symptoms include coughing,
throat irritation, pain,
burning, discomfort or tightness
in the chest, wheezing,
or shortness of breath.
Zero: Wow, ZERO is happy to
have unfeeling automaton organs.
Scientist: Yes,
you should be.
And if a person breathes in
too much ozone or a lot over
a long period of time, then
the effects are greater, and
can lead to death.
Zero: If I were capable of
expressing colorful metaphor,
I would be expressing one now.
Zero: I am glad you
stopped me from spraying
more people with ozone.
My trip to Hollywood, Florida
might have been cancelled.
Zero: So we have learned
about stratospheric and
tropospheric ozone, how they
form, where they exist and why,
and health effects of
both on puny humans.
Do I require more data?
Scientist: Well, there is one
more present day matter that
I wanted to discuss with
you-ozone depletion.
Zero: Ozone depletion?
Explain, Human.
Scientist: Let's get back
to my lab so I can show you.
Scientist: So remember how
the ozone layer protects
Earth from UV rays?
Zero: Affirmative.
Scientist: Well, ozone
depletion is a decrease in
the amount of ozone
in the ozone layer.
This allows more harmful
UV rays to reach earth.
Zero: But this
increases human risk to
skin cancer and cataracts!
Query, why is the
ozone layer depleting?
Scientist: Starting in the
1920s, people began using
chlorofluorocarbon, or
CFC, in refrigerators and
aerosol sprays.
CFC is a VOC, made of
carbon, chlorine, and fluorine.
Scientist: CFC compounds
don't react with anything in
the lower atmosphere so they
go into the upper atmosphere
where UV rays break them
apart into individual atoms.
Scientist: Then, some of
chlorine atoms STEAL oxygen
atoms from the
unstable ozone molecules,
turning the ozone
back into oxygen.
This entire process is
known as ozone depletion.
Zero: Why do you say only
some chlorine atoms?
Scientist: I think
we'll need a visual.
Let's go back to space.
Scientist: As I mentioned
previously, CFCs go into
the atmosphere, where
the chlorines are
photochemically separated.
Scientist: Then, most chlorine
atoms bond with other chemicals.
These new stable molecules
follow air currents to
different places
in the stratosphere.
Scientist: When these compounds
eventually end up at the poles,
polar vortexes and stratospheric
clouds separate the chlorines,
then the chlorine atoms bond
with the oxygen atoms from
ozone in the ozone layer,
thereby depleting the ozone.
Scientist: This creates
ozone holes above the
North and South Poles.
Zero: That sounds like peril.
I guess it is good that
nobody lives on those Poles...
except all those tiny
black and white humans with
beaks I see down there.
Zero: Hello,
little humans.
They are so funny.
Scientist: That's true.
But Australia is very
close to the large ozone
hole over Antarctica.
Scientist: Australians suffer
from the highest rates of
skin cancer, with
about 1,200 Australians
dying every year
from the disease.
Zero: Zealous
Empathy activated!
So to summarize, ozone
depletion happens everywhere,
even over London, Kentucky.
Zero: But ozone holes are
only occurring over the Poles.
Both are mainly caused
by CFC emissions.
Scientist: Yes, that's right.
Zero: Now that we know
about this, humans have
stopped using
CFCs, affirmative?
Scientist: Yes, after 1985,
when CFCs' effects on the
ozone layer were discovered,
people began using alternatives.
Scientist: However, CFCs
stay in the atmosphere for
a long time, and some
alternatives also had
similar, but lesser effects.
Zero: I require a
situation report, Human.
Scientist: Recently, scientists
are saying that the ozone holes
are becoming smaller because
humans aren't
using anymore CFCs.
Zero: This is beneficial.
Query, do you have
anything else?
Scientist: No, I think
that's all I have
to tell you about ozone.
Zero: Standby!
Information processing.
Scientist: And now you
know that you shouldn't
spray people with ozone.
Zero: Affirmative.
And I also know where
ozone should be sprayed.
Zero: Look!
Zero is a HEEERROOOO!
Zero: This has been a
presentation from
the US National Library of Medicine.
Zero: For info on Ozone,
visit the Environmental
Health Student Portal.
Zero is a Hero!!!
Zero: I have learned from
the error of my ways.
I will help humans
in a different way.
Zero: Humans use
Hydrochloric acid to
help them dissolve their
food particles for digestion.
So-I will help you CEASE
this endless chewing!